[Musique]
vous avez fait rêver des millions de
Françaises et de français jusque là et
encore aujourd'hui ils ont vibré
et vous avez fait rêver des milliards de
gens qui ont regardé ce match
parce que vous avez fait du grand
football et du Grand Sport
les leçons voulaient le tirer il y aura
sans doute des regrets après ce match
après quand il manque un truc dans la
vie c'est pareil c'est le fond c'est le
c'est le sport ça vous éprouvez rien
mais vous avez eu le cœur la fin l'envie
et le talent d'y aller rien que pour ça
je voulais venir vous voir pour vous
dire merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y en a plein qui sont très jeunes
qui vont en faire beaucoup d'autres plus
que moi comme président il se fout bien
vous allez en gagner des autres parce
que vous avez une expérience embarquée
qui est dingue
[Musique]
en tout cas moi je suis fier de vous
vive la république et vive la France